are different too Angela listen you're a
Brooklyn native your mom is black your
dad is Chinese how did that upbringing
shape who you are today I think that
growing up in New York and in Brooklyn
and with different ethnicities it helps
to be a lot more empathetic to our
people just because I had all these
different cultures that I was dealing
with and I saw a lot of the different
clashes and so for me I feel like in New
York you know when you're here you see a
lot and it takes a lot to shock me so
even doing my podcast and doing my show
you would have to really do something
off the wall for me to be like this is
crazy you got Stone faced most of the
time yeah you hear a lot of crazy things
all the time and I see a lot of crazy
things and I know a lot of crazy things